Bleacher Report's Matt Miller draft
expert here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Matt hey rich good to talk to
you again man I don't mind holding to
listen to to get all caught up on the
fight that it was the Pittsburgh
Steelers locker room I'm always happy to
look into that it's it's amazing how
again Antonio Brown says he's moving
past it he's in a new place and and and
the Raiders would love him to move on
but clearly there's some sort of animus
towards a guy that does not appear to
have a single reasoning bone in his body
to have animus thrown in his direction
it's really something else what are the
Steelers gonna do in the draft do you
think when they finally come on the
clock 20th overall I know where that
that's best player available territory
but what do you think their plan is with
no brown and no bail do they replace him
you know I don't think they do racing on
the first round like if you look at the
way this team has built you know even
juju was a second-round pick you know I
tell you about the date three picks so
they have not gone the route of
replacing skilled players with
first-round picks this is more of a fun
office with the Kevin Gilbert and the
guys there Kevin Kolb excuse me there
they think offensive line and defensive
and defense in the first round so I
think like they really like James
Washington the guy in the second round
last year on Oklahoma State they brought
in guys like Donte Moncrief from free
agency obviously James Conner was wiped
out last year and taking over for $11 so
I think that's more of a team that you
can look at they really swung him this
with Artie burns in the first round of
2016 they need another corner and this
could be an area where the best corner
and the draft in my opinion LSU is
reading Williams to come off the board
it's not expected to be a year like last
year where dental work went forth
overall and there's a little bit of a
run on the corner position this year
because of the quarterbacks the great
edge rusher and defensive lineman some
offensive tackles we could see the
corners to push down very great spot to
get someone who has a pleasant play
ability to come in opposite Joe hey so
I'm gonna ask you Matt Miller the same
question I'm asking everybody who's
locked in plugged into the draft or the
NFL information community have you come
across anybody scouts general managers
anybody any source of you
that says hold on a minute the Cardinals
may not take Carla Marie
no not one and you know you and I talked
at the combine and and it was the same
thing then so it's like it's here we are
you know month later nothing is changing
and and I will say this I've written
about this I've talked about it on my
podcast
going back to early January what cliff
king is very started interviewing with
jobs he started when it was known that
he was going to interview and maybe
leave USC that's when this news started
to come out this isn't you know this
isn't a smokescreen here at the end of
the draft process this is something that
people have been reporting now for three
months so I'm glad you put it that way
because I haven't been able to find
anyone who thinks that someone other
than Kyle Armour will be that pick and I
think if you look at even you know like
when we write mock drafts we don't want
to be right you know that that's the
goal of my draft is to be right to
educate your readers about what could
happen what we're hearing will happen I
bet if you went looked at the you know
the top draft analyst everybody's gonna
have the same ticket number one right
now well the issue with that Matt is you
know wanting to be right with a mock
draft is that does happen
calimary everyone's right up there then
somebody's going to be wrong with who
the Giants or the Redskins take or
somebody else because somebody's going
to have their their first-round draft
selection other than a quarterback
because they've acquired Josh Rosen so
what I agree completely what are you
hearing on that front the rows in front
you know I still think that it is
Washington or bust at this point and I
think everyone wanted to connect the
Giants there because they had the two
first round picks I haven't heard of
anyone that wants to try the first round
pick for Josh Rose and I think the
Cardinals would do backflips right now
if that were even rumored it feels like
the Chargers are out of it after they
deliver says never I've been told been
super open to the idea of you know kind
of having the quarterbacks in Waiting
system and they they signed Tyrod Taylor
to a decent deal is back up it really
feels like it will be Washington and for
a number of reasons they need to win
quickly or Jay Gruden's gonna be looking
for a new job
they're also picking a 15 in the first
round so it's it's less likely that they
would be able to get a dwayne Haskins or
drew lock at that spot one of the guys
that most Scouts believe it's a plugin
guy instead you can look where they're
you know they're picking up 46 overall
and I think that's a pretty good return
on investment if they want to flip 46
Arizona the Cardinals might be able to
get you know something a little bit
extra day three to kind of save face a
little bit but they're not gonna get the
15th pick in the first round and so I
think with Washington if it looked like
or feel like Kyler's gonna go one
maybe Haskins goes top eight maybe drew
Locke goes top ten you're weighing the
decision of okay we like Daniel Jones
from Duke enough to take him here or do
we trade a second-round pick and get a
player that everyone agreed was a top
ten guy last year Matt Miller bleacher
report draft compadre hear from my my
bleacher report community again you can
listen to us be our live.com every
single day his stick to football podcast
can be also gotten throughout the
bleacher report platform on your on your
mock draft you do have Haskins going to
the Giants at 6:00 drew Locke going to
the Broncos at 10:00 and Jones to the
Redskins at 15 again that's where one of
them might pop up somehow and take a
rosin there because the that trades
gonna have to be announced almost
hand-in-hand with the drafting of Murray
so that Cardinals can't use a draft
choice in short order and then I'm
seeing on your mock draft you've got ed
Oliver going to the Packers at 12th
overall I think the Packers and all
their fans will hit their knees every
night between now and the first night of
the draft that you are right there I'm
here in Oliver's top five potentially
because of how much people love him and
Comp him with Aaron Donald why do you
have Oliver falling to 12 what are you
hearing yeah you know he kind of gets
stuck with that tweener label I I love
him as well he's a top six player on my
rankings I think we were overthinking
him a little bit because he got hurt
this past year didn't have great
production but he was one of the few
players like we hear like oh he was
double-teamed ed Oliver was legitimately
double teaching the times he was triple
team and had to play nose tackle at
Houston because they they needed him to
play and plug the middle of that line so
I wouldn't be shocked if he goes for to
Oakland but I think there's also a lot
of conversation about players like
Rashad Gary you know where does quite a
Williams go
we're Devon white go and unfortunately
when you have a lot of good players in
that same kind of tear someone has to
fall and I think when I learn to
monetize I might've been two or three
weeks ago and it was at the point where
like at all that looks like the guy who
could be dropping a little bit at that
time you know he's a great athlete I
don't see the Aaron Donald comp I think
he's more of like a Gerald McCoy or a
Gina lacus were still really good
players and he should be he's a good top
ten pick like someone has to fall
especially if we see a lot of
quarterbacks like you said with the drew
lock goes 10 and Dwayne Haskins goes 6
which even now that's starting to look a
little outdated but if that happened
some good players are gonna have to
folder what's the wildest rumor you've
heard to date man well I thought you
know Kylie married Roman wild back I
think right now probably the craziest
talk is that drew Locke from Missouri a
top five pick at quarterback and it
could be the second one drafting so
ahead of Dwayne Haskin so I think a lot
of folks have felt like you know he is
going to be the number two quarterback
off the board and and maybe even you'll
compete with Murray for a true number
one great but I think there's a lot of
like for drew Locke because you had a
great senior role process he's a
three-year starter at Missouri so maybe
a little more Pro ready than someone
like Haskins it was just a one year
starter at Ohio State and didn't play
and you know not quite an NFL style
system so drew walk moving up right now
he's probably the the most exciting room
as a dress it's kind of a dead period
right now with teams being a draft
meetings guys don't have a lot of time
to you know hop on the phone and
chitchat about the draft just the one
thing that I'm a last thing for you here
matter I'd love to get your two cents on
it my guy here Brockman has been
pounding the table on this a little bit
too and I just want to start delving
into this in terms of what so crazy
rumor or a wrinkle for the lack of
better phrase that would throw this
whole thing this chessboard up in the
air certainly when you talk about Locke
being the top five is why are the
Raiders meeting with Murray and having
dinner with him and they brought Haskins
in why are they doing that if Antonio
Brown and Derek Carr are kind of like
the new step brothers you know they're
all tight now what's what what is that
all I screwed in just a tape quarterback
grinding junkie I mean what are you what
do you make of all this man
man hey you know MIT mike Mayock better
than anybody in the world he's probably
a BS or I know I mean I don't know I
mean Mike Mike Mike definitely loves
evaluating people and he would evaluate
it he would evaluate all positions yeah
so and I don't know even if really it's
it's his last call here but if Derek
Carr is the guy if he's your guy and
you're committing to him and he you know
why why do you spend the time on on
these prospects I think you call it due
diligence you might be able to also say
maybe it is you know in the hopes that
someone will trade up to that number
three pick with the New York Jets and to
take a quarterback ahead of Oakland and
then push a better player down and I
think that's the most likely thing
because it would surprise me frankly if
they did go out if you add players not
just a B but you know to go get the
Tyrell Williams to get the impacts that
they have a receiver and then make a
change at quarterback with you know
whether wherever you come down on Derek
Carr get a card you know what you're
getting you know he's only 28 years old
he's taking you to the playoffs before I
would be a little surprised if they went
ahead and moved on but so for me that
interest is more trying to get someone
maybe the New York Giants to panic and
move up to number three where the Jets
it right now and then in turn that
pushes Quintin Williams or Devon white
right into the laps of the Raiders
intrigue
thank you Matt appreciate the call we'll
chat again soon before the draft looking
at NFL Draft Scout is how you can fall
on that for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app